you are in the final eight but you've
got some work to do we do my team is
confident um we are calling we're
meeting colleagues we had two hustings
last night another one after i leave the
studio
before the voting begins uh properly at
1 30. um i have got the track record
for delivery i delivered the vaccine
program i
focused the department of education on
skills schools families i've spoken to
you about this here many times if i'm
prime minister i will focus the
government on delivery delivery delivery
we've got two years to deliver for
people to demonstrate that we are on
their side i have
five pledges that i've made i will
cut taxes uh next year i'll bring
forward that
basic rate cut down to 19
reverse the
corporation tax
rise that's really important of course
we know fuel bills are high uh so i will
pause v80 and uh the green levees for
two years while still keeping an eye on
making sure we meet our net zero targets
by 2050
you know we've got to invest more in
defense 2.5 of gdp by 2025 is what i
want to deliver and then of course
we inherited a load of bureaucracy from
europe on our statute books i will ask
businesses to lead a review of all the
bureaucracy see what we can actually get
rid of we've got a financial services
bill that i am shortly i hope
introducing which will begin to
demonstrate to not just the city of
london but financial services around the
country we've got 2.2 million people who
work in financial services that we are
going to make the most of brexit and the
opportunities of brexit on that and the
final one
of course police are focused on
fighting crime violent crime and cyber
crime fraud is a big thing but the what
i call the pipeline into the courts is
really blocked up clogged and i want to
unblock that by investing in our court
system and of course paying criminal
barristers properly uh those are my five
pledges and if my colleagues vote for me
today and i'm prime minister i will have
a relentless focus on delivery delivery
okay pitch over um the governor of the
bank of england said what on earth are
you up to promising tax cuts outside of
a budget
well i'm a candidate um in this uh
election i was talked about tax cuts if
i'm prime minister talking about
bringing them forward to next year when
i know because the governor's focus on
is because he and i speak uh that he
wants to see interest rates going up
temporarily because we want to abate
inflation the way we do that is by being
fiscally responsible now today in the
next few days i'll be saying more on
public sector pay we've had the pay
review body's recommendations back we
all have to come together because
inflation is the one that can really
hurt those people that we are trying to
protect
and so
my
pledges are fully costed i will uh
publish them i've had
72 hours uh in this
campaign but i think it's the right
thing to do set up my my stool that i
will demonstrate where i find the head
room to be able to deliver this next
year the governor will also agree that
he wants to see um inflation abate and
he sees interest rates being high
temporarily so we're both on the same
page on this you labor sat there just a
second ago saying what a load of
nonsense you're talking when you're
saying that there's that much flab in
government departments 20 and i told him
that you had costed 20 when you were
education secretary he said you're not
spending as much money on kids now as we
did 10 years ago they would say that
wouldn't they uh labor they have no plan
um
i like all other departments was tasked
by the prime minister by the then
chancellor uh to look at my head count
in education
it was you know a tough ask we took two
weeks to go literally line by line we
have eight thousand four hundred people
in department they want us to get close
to twenty percent reduction in head
count uh we've delivered our our
submission to now the new chancellor uh
and uh the current prime minister and if
we manage to do that across government
that will help with inflation when i
talk to my uh uh team at the treasury
when i described to them because i was
on the other side of that um negotiation
as secretary of state for education they
said of course it will help because when
you reduce the head count government you
reduce the cost of government the
biggest cost in government is is wages
salaries right when you reduce that that
help and of course um as we see
inflation abate the other thing that
will happen is the debt interest
payments should also come down they're
higher than they're projected to be high
at the moment okay so they're going to
hit 83 billion this is the debt that we
pace almost the budget of the department
of education right it was only 20
billion last year yeah rishi is right on
that but if we do the job properly why
is he doing so much better than you well
he is a great candidate i am proud to
call him a friend and a fellow traveler
on this journey look at the look at the
the the list of votes like sweetie is
apparently look at that look at look at
the the the people who are standing four
women four men ethnically diverse full
of talent labor would give their right
arm for this quality of of talent um on
the conservative benches and i'm very
proud of that and my colleagues will
make a decision what my pitch to them is
i am the man who delivers the next two
years will be all about delivery our
constituents will judge us by what we
deliver whether it is
vaccines in the past education i'm
building 50 schools a year will build a
hundred in the next two years if those
hundred constituencies can see those
schools built modern methods of
construction
on time on budget then that is how we
level up
listen hey you will know this you lose
because you come from wigan right you'll
know this right
the
greatest investment we can make in the
global race for prosperity the nation
that invests in skills that develops
young people into healthy well-rounded
adult that are highly skilled wins that
race my ambition is to deliver that
all over the country look at what i did
on the leveling up white paper in terms
of ambitions for primary school kids 90
to get maths and english whereas it's
about 65
uh currently hit by the pandemic as well
we have to focus on investing in skills
the way we invest in infrastructure
that's what i will do that is my pledge
to
my my colleagues but also to the nation
okay you've had three week books this
morning um talk to me about uh why
people are so voting for rishi sunak
though what what is it his appeal and
why then penny mordant apparently so
we're told and liz trust and then
there's several of you down towards the
bottom well colleagues will be making
their mind up i think the qualities i
speak to um uh last night the hustlings
i attended i had some great feedback
from both hustings we've got another
hustlings uh to come and colleagues
decide uh who they want to back there's
a lot of undeclared
colleagues remain um yes rishi is out in
the lead no doubt he's a very talented
man uh he would make a great prime
minister of course why should they vote
for him
but i think i can deliver i am the man
who has a track record of operational
competence what the nation wants to see
from a conservative prime minister is
that we are operationally competent we
can deliver for people to change their
lives the the the the um the difference
i think the next two years will make is
who can focus on delivery and i i have
the track record for delivering in
vaccine and i hope i've demonstrated in
education i can do the same focus the
department skills schools families and
deliver that and that is my pledge to my
colleagues okay and the nation body
language expert said you've got the
power thumb as well you do this all the
time were you aware that you did that uh
what happened with sajid javid
um
i haven't spoken to him yet um he um
clearly felt the thing it is bruising it
listen this is a a a a
um yeah a difficult time um for those
who got knocked out and those who
decided obviously to not stand as well
they are brilliant colleagues sergeant
jared has got a lot to offer uh uh the
country and of course the conservative
party and i'm sure uh he will uh return
he is a huge talent again you know a a a
son of a of a bus driver who uh never
mentions it became who became you know
chancellor the exchequer health
secretary yeah what a reflection on
our great party and our great country
this is the greatest country on earth
okay to take an immigrant boy from iraq
who couldn't speak a word of english and
make him chancellor of the exchequer and
member of parliament for shakespeare the
heart of england there is no greater
country on earth good to talk to you
great uh let's see how you get on five
o'clock this afternoon we should know
shouldn't we whether you've made it
through to the next round or not good to
see you thank you very much indeed thank
you